well home is where the heart is for
katherine heigl and her
singer-songwriter hubby josh kelly
they're raising their kids away from the
hollywood spotlight on a family farm in
utah and lauren zema got an exclusive
give me tour numbers how many horses do
you guys keep uh i think we have like 12
horses okay uh 12 chickens yes a nursery
rhyme and we have two pigs and two goats
i want to see the farm it is raining
yeah is this you've given me this is
this a farm
umbrella this is the only thing i could
find that was gonna work to shield us
from the rain
okay so chicken coop yeah chicken coop
right over here
okay oh hi
josh what are they wanting from me that
i'm not i don't have for them they want
hay right hey
some country singers are faking it we're
legit down here
yeah josh catherine and their three kids
are pretty much living off the grid on
their ranch you know we're we're out
here in the middle of nowhere we just
sort of stay to ourselves unless i go on
tour unless my wife goes and makes a
movie or tv show we were already living
a very quarantined life anyway on the
property there's also josh's studio a
bar and this riding arena where
nine-year-old adelaide gets practice in
the saddle
can you tell us the source's
well name she'll sit next to me and i'm
like what do you think of that mix and
she goes it sounds a little bass heavy
to me i'm like thanks
[Laughter]
farm fella who can sing two thumbs up
now you unreal so what makes your
relationship so special
um you know we just really balance each
other and i really do believe in this
statement you know when they say when
you know you know
ooh you hear that lori harvey says
michael b jordan is in game y'all so you
know we had to do yes we had to go talk
to her daddy i spoke exclusively to
steve harvey who told me michael is
already family
i bumped into somebody you know oh so
well michael b
jordan he is genuinely who he looks like
he is it threw me off at first because
he was so kind i figured okay this is
the game right right but it wasn't man
this dude was sincere they're doing well
i'm in love with lloyd to death to the
moon and back i'll hurt you about him i
really will and you can ask him steve
now hold up i want to ask you has he
commented on your fashions not that i
know of michael b jordan knows better
than to challenge the king of the
three-piece suit but steve's switching
up his style and adding more vibrant
colors this season steve on watch is
back with an in-studio audience on
facebook watch and he gave us an
exclusive look inside his wardrobe let's
go let's go to the rack that suit pops
right there this is called it's called
papalicious
ellie caramel he is my stylist describe
it tell me what it is every piece from
dolce that we wear is one of one this is
fendi by kim jones we make the time the
exact fabric and color of the shirt
these shoes right here
these are christian dior high tops look
steve we didn't wear those kind of shoes
throw it up
but he wears them with suits and the
biggest fight we had was
i don't want to wear a high-top sneaker
with a suit but i wore an armani sneaker
that don't look like a sneaker tell us
how every man can add a little style
like steve has my trick honestly is to
simplify um formality this is tom ford
it's a vibrant vibrant piece hey that's
a lie kevin this is not for you
it could be for you no you won't you
lose your job at ut if you wear this
you know what steve harvey is becoming a
style icon and i kind of like it all
right now to comedy legend mr bob
newhart you know bob is still cracking
us up after more than six decades in the
biz and only one show is at home with
the ever humble comedian
it's the man the myth the comedy icon
the one and only bob newhart the e.t
exclusive
[Music]
first of all how are you feeling i feel
great i just turned 92. it's been a
great life it's just you know making
people laugh is
it's wonderful i love you america
and america loves you right back bob i
mean what an honor it was spending the
day with this legend at his los angeles
home he's celebrating 62 years in show
business
hello
for me bob newhart's show was like it
was appointment viewing well we were at
cbs saturday night lineup all in the
family
mash
mary tyler moore us and carol burnett
and we used to get like
super bowl numbers
bob shot his show on the cbs radford lot
which is also where we shoot e.t
that has such great memories i spent 14
years there and mary tyler moore was at
seinfeld with her
but bob had a little-known secret
i had the lines on the back of a cereal
box the director he said cut cut cut cut
said bob
nobody turns the cereal box around i
said okay you're right you're right but
that's where the words were there are
some real top i mean i see richard pryor
ed sullivan ted sullivan johnny carson t
martin
bob's home is filled with memories with
his fellow comedians awards magazine
covers even all the scripts from the bob
newhart show and new heart one of his
most treasured pieces of memorabilia is
this letter from jfk signed just five
months before his assassination
it was the president's birthday and i
entertained at it
and
received a letter from president kennedy
that said enjoyed it greatly that's
amazing i want to play an interview we
did with you in 1986. i mean i belong on
television i don't really belong in
movies i tried movies and they didn't
work movies did work for you
well elf elfwork i'll always be here for
you what was it like making elf
it was a joy
all right let's talk about big bang
theory is he dangerous
how much fun was that it was great i
like
big bang i like the writing on it i
think the cast is incredible any chance
that you could pop up on young sheldon i
hate to say no
you never say no
although bob has won an emmy for acting
his first love was stand-up comedy now
bob is showcasing some of his classic
comedy routines in the vinyl re-release
of his 1992 tv special off the record
which is on sale now how fast were you
going when when mr adams jumped from the
car
some of the early routines i'd like to
do them again
but the most important thing in bob's
life his wife jenny their four kids and
10 grandkids
in a crazy business in a crazy town
you've been married for 58 years
comedians marriages
tend to laugh
there's something about laughter
and the length of a marriage
she knows me she cuts right to to the
bone and
she's been writing time and time again
oh she god if she sees this
[Music]
you